Speaker 1: We are going to hear from some
people in the audience you can call in
via Discord David Pakman dot com slash discord,
and we're going to start today with Clark from
Portland, Oregon. Clark, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. I was just wondering
about what your
Speaker 4: stance was
on lowering the voting age. Obviously, you
know, teenagers pay taxes. Many teenagers
can be emancipated from their parents. And I was
wondering what your stances on that? And also if
you thought that ever be pushed through Congress.
Speaker 1: I think there is not a desire to have
people be able to vote at age 16 or 17, which
generally generally when people say lower the
voting age, they mean 16 or 17. Is that what you
have in mind? Yeah, yeah. I think that there is
a case to be made for that. I think it is widely
seen as being better for the left than the right,
with the assumption that those 16 and 17 year
olds are more likely to vote for Democrats than
Republicans. I don't know if that's actually
true. I think that that's something that I would
want to find data on. I am open to it. I think 17,
more than 16. In theory, the truth is, you know,
the brain is not really fully formed at that point
in time. We know more and more about that. It's
part of the reason why we're seeing some places
push smoking. You know, the age to buy cigarets
looking at 21 instead of 18. I'm not necessarily
looking to to lower ages for things, certainly not
for for driving. And in fact, as someone who got
my license when I was 16 and a half. And thinking
back, my friends driving, it doesn't seem crazy to
raise the age to get your driver's license to 17
or 18. But I don't think that there's much of an
appetite among lawmakers to lower the voting age.
Speaker 4: Yes, certainly. It's just it's tough
to see, especially with all these crazy Trumpists
that are probably a lot less educated than some
16 year olds in my circle. Yeah, and seeing like,
oh, like these guys probably can make a
much better and more informed her voting
decision than a lot of people out there.
Speaker 1: But there's no doubt that anecdotally,
there are lots of 17 year olds that would much be
much more educated as voters than many adults that
vote regularly. That's without a doubt.
Speaker 4: Well, great, thanks, David,
I'm glad. Glad to hear your opinion on that.
Speaker 1: Pleasure. Thank you so much for
the call. There is a clerk asking
about lowering the voting age.